ils ont choisi la ferme de grignon pour
une sortie pendant les vacances
d'automne plusieurs visiteurs venus en
famille à la découverte des conditions
de vie des vaches de l'exploitation
notamment les 40 kg de nourriture donnée
à chaque bête par jour prim'holstein
pour la petite histoire la holstein est
une région donc situe entre l'allemagne
et la hollande et on les appelle les
prim'holstein
parce que ce sont les premières vaches à
avoir été exportées vers l'étranger
aujourd'hui la prim'holstein c'est
l'arrêt ce qu'on rencontre le plus
souvent dans le monde parce que c'est
celle qui produit le plus de lettres
contrairement à ce qu'on croit à une
vague ne boit que de l'eau
elle ne boit pas de lait d'accord ni de
jus d'orange
on est d'accord la rencontre avec les
animaux se poursuit avec les veaux
élevés séparés de leur mère pour
consommer du lait en bonne quantité
il ya aussi la bergerie avec des brebis
et leurs petits agneaux g20 jeudi des
gnocchis des tests auprès de sa mère et
quand je me suis approché ici en fille
soit et c'est très mignon direction
ensuite la laiterie le lieu où le lait
est transformé en yaourts crème fraîche
ou mises en briques
on peut donc pas entrer à l'intérieur
pour des raisons d'hygiène alors l'idée
c'est vraiment de réussir à reconstituer
toutes les étapes de leur bol est
finalement et de l'herbe aux produits
laitiers qu'en définitive donc essayer
de comprendre un peu tout ce qui se
passe avant le d'avoir le yaourt servi
sur la table directement après la visite
de la ferme place à un jeux sensoriels
le but déguster et devinez des saveurs
et le parfum des yaourts produits à la
ferme racid c'est comme le citron c'est
comme le citron
citroën n'ont donc c'est quoi ce qui
fait mal
l'odeur aller forte le goût il est sucré
bas de la cannelle mais après pas grand
chose la ferme est ouverte au public
tous les jours pour des visites libres
durant toute l'année